mcdonald's is suing its own former ceo
over allegations of workplace misconduct
steve easterbrook was fired last year
over a relationship at work
that was not physical since then three
alleged sexual affairs with mcdonald's
employees have come to light
and the company says he tried to cover
them up tarika duncan has been following
these allegations jericho good morning
good morning to you anthony as you
mentioned that former mcdonald's ceo
steve
easterbrook he was terminated without
cause
last fall and when he left he retained
42 million dollars
in cash and stock options well now
mcdonald's is suing
to get that money back
mcdonald's claims in a lawsuit filed
monday that former ceo steve easterbrook
lied to company investigators about
inappropriate sexual relationships
he allegedly had with employees last
year easter brook was fired for having
an alleged consensual relationship with
a female employee
consisting of text messages and video
calls
at the time he told investigators he had
never had a physical sexual relationship
with any mcdonald's employee but
according to court documents
last month mcdonald's received an
anonymous report
about a second mcdonald's employee who
engaged in a sexual relationship with
easter brook
while he was ceo the anonymous report
prompted a new investigation into easter
brook
which mcdonald's alleges revealed the
businessman had sexual relationships
with three other mcdonald's employees
not including the employee linked to his
firing
new york times correspondent and cbs
news contributor jody cantor
this is a me too story with a twist
because mcdonald's the top fast food
company
in the country is now going after
its former ceo not only for having
inappropriate relationships in the
workplace
but for concealing that according to the
lawsuit investigators found easter brook
sent
emails from his corporate account
containing dozens of nude partially nude
or sexually explicit photographs and
videos of women
including employees taken in 2018 and
2019
mcdonald's also alleges that easter
brook granted one of the women
special stock benefits worth hundreds of
thousands of dollars
shortly after their first sexual
encounter mcdonald's has been working to
reshape its image following
allegations of systemic sexual
harassment last summer the company
introduced a training and engagement
initiative
with a focus on safe and respectful work
environments
current mcdonald's ceo chris kamchinski
addressed the company's values recently
on cbs this morning there's a strong
desire for us to be talking about values
because it's a common vocabulary as it's
what
makes mcdonald's such a special company
what does this do for morale for a
company like mcdonald's
well depends on what you think is more
important the fact that it happened
or the fact that the company is having a
very strong response
he had been kind of a rock star so the
fact that he was fired over this and
that now he faces even more
accountability
is significant
cbs news has reached out to steve
easterbook for comment and has not heard
back yet
michelle wow eureka thank you